Salut ! Aujourd'hui je vous donne d'abord la réponse de l'énigme d'hier, si vous ne l'avez pas regardé allez la voir elle est hyper intéressante
en fonction de cette réponse là.
Mais comme la réponse je la donne maintenant, si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme allez la voir de suite.
Pour résoudre cette énigme il faut créer un paradoxe.
Un paradoxe, c'est par exemple, si je vous dis:
"Cette phrase est fausse."
C'est un paradoxe.
Parce que si ma phrase est fausse, ça veut dire qu'elle est vraie.
Mais si elle est vraie, ça veut dire qu'elle est fausse.
Mais si elle est fausse, ça veut dire qu'elle est vraie. Et donc il n'y a jamais de solution, c'est un paradoxe complet.
Et c'est exactement ce qu'on va faire devant le génie.
La question que vous allez lui poser c'est:
"Est-ce que la prochaine réponse que vous allez me donner est "non" ?"
Il ne peut pas répondre à ça. Parce que si il répond "oui", alors il a menti.
Or, souvenez vous le génie ne peut pas mentir.
Mais si il dit "non", alors ça ne marche pas, il a menti aussi parce qu'il vient de dire "non", donc il aurait dû dire "oui".
Êt là vous avez créé un paradoxe.
Donc il ne peut pas répondre à la question, donc vous pouvez passer.
J'avoue elle était un peu galère celle-là, mais je la trouvais hyper interessante dans son explication.
Et l'énigme d'aujourd'hui sera moins compliquée et c'est maintenant.
Enigme de plage, pour l'énigme 5 ! [chante]
Non je n'ai pas chanté... N'importe quoi !
Enigme 5: un touriste va à la plage.
Sur son trajet, il croise:
2 femmes ayant chacune 2 enfants, 1 couple avec 1 chien, 3 adolescents qui sont ensemble, et l'un des enfants a un landau avec un petit poupon (un bébé).
Ma question est: Combien de personne(s) vont à la plage ?
Cherchez, essayez de trouver, attention comme dans toutes les énigmes, la première réponse qui vous viendra ne sera peut-être pas la bonne.
Vous pouvez en parler dans les commentaires, mais ne mettez pas la réponse, laissez les autres chercher.
Par contre dès que vous avez trouvé mettez un pouce en l'air pour qu'on voie le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la solution.
On le sait maintenant ce que je veux pour vous.
Il faut que vous profitiez du soleil, que vous passiez un bel été, que vous vous abonniez à la chaine.
Et rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !